now this light makes me suspicious it
makes me very suspicious it's it's true
but it's correct it's not suspicious cuz
it's wrong I'm suspicious because the
numbers look very very similar to the
numbers that i started with do you see
the similarities right the first thing
those obvious thing is there's just a
number which is literally transcribed
right there okay don't answer this just
think about it is that a coincidence
there's another number there's another
robot that looks very very suspicious
right this 25 looks like that right
what's five square isn't it that makes
really sauce okay now mathematicians we
always say or when there's a pattern
when we see in is a patent I want you to
take away all the arbitrary assumptions
I've made like I assumed okay x equals 5
how about that I made that the point
where I started I would things with the
patent carry through if I didn't say it
was particularly because it's fine it's
fine like a special number is not a
special number is that why that's the
case okay now remember when I talked to
you before we do a big colored chart
which are jiu-jitsu distinction between
physics and mathematics and how we both
look at motion okay if you're a
physicist and you notice a pattern like
this okay you say huh that's we in
better do another experiment and do it
with different parameters and all that
kind of thing right and we see if we
observe the same pattern okay
mathematicians take a different line
okay rather than doing it again but with
different numbers mathematicians have
this superpower I can do this for every
number all at once I can just say
consider now we begin with negative 9x
right if you're a physicist you can only
make your machine do a set one thing at
a certain time less squawking physics
pen I don't going to get into that okay
I can make this every single number all
at once I'm just going to let it equal
an arbitrary number I'm going to go back
to the differential equation where this
came from right so now I'm considering
it for any value
they're not just n equals 3 which use me
as quite a good life I'm considering any
and you like right fair be positive
don't really matter in the same way I
want to consider any different value of
like I called this the amplitude right
now called the a so let's call it x
equals a some arbitrary efforts you
whatever you like right so I'm going to
say that's my differential equation and
the velocity is zero at this arbitrary
now you ok what's going to happen let's
just quickly muchly we've done most of
the legwork let's see if the pattern
holds ok I'm going to answer the same
question i'm going to start the same way
so i'm going to go i think the
derivative of half B squared equals this
is just this guy you give n squared X so
what did we do at this point over here
we integrate with astro 2x ok so i'm
going to the same thing here i'm going
to get my half v squared that leaves me
with minus and squared and x squared on
to write because of that n squared is
just that clips that hanging out the
front plus half of this sky and the
constant of information and then i
multiply everything that through by to
write because i just wanted to be swear
huh so you see here two things have
happened right you ended up with a
division by 2 here cuz you had to see
this X the power goes up you divide
through by the power but that too is
always going to vanish it's not just a
coincidence that you get left with n
square X square it has to right so tell
you my name whoops thank you ok it's not
just a coincidence that that n squared
there that this 9 ended up here and
therefore ended up here that's where it
comes from it has to end up there no
matter what n is it's not a coincidence
in the same way I'm going to evaluate
what this constant is and I'm going to
use my condition up here right when
at x equals 0 V equals 0 okay so when
you see here where my don't get me minus
n squared a squared plus my constant
equals 0 squared right so you can see
here okay look you just drank over like
so remember here i pointed out are we
just wrote down to 25 because that's
what my times 25 is right but you don't
need to have to factor that in you're
going to get that in swear that nine
it's always going to come along for the
right that's why you're always going to
be able to do this factorization so
therefore what am I got you three
squared equals I'm going to put my
constant back into my internet in same
it right so then i'm going to factor out
that and spread like i did before and
rearrange it so I've got pauses up front
bigger than you okay so what do we
observe here this is our final
differential equation refer to all of
them now our final differential equation
for simple humble admission okay when
you see you see these jewelry when you
see this one which is where we started
just like before just like before you
read ok this is super fun with plumber
measured number one and it's about the
origin yes how do i how a little
different if it's not about the origin
you're going to have minus x squared
let's do but it'd be X take away
whatever you want X naught be whatever
you want to call that became and that's
going to be your new center of motion ok
so we already know what these are if you
see is a V squared right and just be
careful I'm pointing out the similarity
between these so that you do it is
subtly different and you can tell them
apart have a look at this
you've got a lot of survivors there you
still got this factorized thing in there
right but what you're looking at is V
squared not acceleration okay and you've
got this difference here has nothing to
do with what are we looking at here has
nothing to do with the center of worship
right this has to be about the origin
you see that that's where we started has
to be about the origin so really this is
a particular sub case obvious you get a
new one if you do it about the origin
right but what this tells you is not
about like where it where is your Center
aggression it tells you how far your you
will you moved from your Center version
as well as how quickly you do that does
that make sense so if you get something
like this you can straight away read off
period amplitude you can't read our
starting point but that's okay often
that's not that important you don't care
where you begin you're going to do the
same thing everything anyway forever
does that make sense okay so if you are
if you've written down that you should
put a box around it like I said even
though you're like wow these are really
different really really different right
after status acceleration versus V
squared Samuel E and you've got an x
squared in there not an act so it is a
quadratic not a linear function they
look quite different but by the time you
kind of like you're letting all these
pleasures all together I want students I
find quite frequently confuse these two
they encounter a question you're
supposed to use this one but they'll use
that or vice versa is there any benefit
with the square numbers right is the
difference of squares is there any
benefit to factorize that you would
further to like to get the amplitude as
a number dated Lee dance where group it
means anyone
oh I see what you mean you mean I'm just
getting yeah do you mean riding it like
this is there any benefit in practice I
doubt it in most cases I mean if you if
you see something like this you're like
oh square number right if it were say
eleven take away x squared I would not
bother to go further and say square root
11 minus x squared plus X I'd say okay
irie off that I suppose I would write
here if I wanted to do that if anything
and I don't think this is necessary I
would prefer to write it like that
because there's a up ace a squared take
away x squared so the amplitude is
squared away okay see exactly okay so
simple harmonic motion Lee bow around it
that's the last one okay that's the last
one you'll have to deal with but now the
challenge for you will be ok I know so
much about simple harmonic motion now
remember when we had to say okay where
do we begin that's the hardest question
I think it's trickiest question-answer
what's you know where to begin you just
sort of just go for it kind of unfolds
by itself because you have to integrate
with respect to a certain variable if
you chose the right one you just kind of
fold out okay